anh
alo alo
à à
chỉ
có hai người đánh chờ xem
Xin
chào các bạn
Hôm nay thì à Đây là một buổi lại cốt
theo kiểu mình chưa chuẩn bị một cái gì
cả mình thì Lúc đầu định kiểu chuẩn bị
trước ấy đề phòng là hôm nay sợ sợ cố
trong vòng 1 tiếng thì sợ Có thể lâu lâu
hơn có thể thế không biết nhanh hơn
không Có thể lâu hơn bởi vì mình cũng
vừa mới ngủ dậy để mình đang hơi bia
A gọi là hơi không tình báo lắm đầu vẫn
nó hơi choáng hôm nay
về sáng nay mình vẫn còn phải học lên
thông nó thứ thì nhưng mà thôi để mình
thử thử xem à
2055 giờ mà thỉnh thoảng 5 giờ chiều còn
tối thì bị trùng lịch với thầy hiệu
trưởng với anh Tuấn như là thôi mình mới
kiểu chuyển qua dậy buổi chiều
Ờ Ờ
nói chung là đây là một buổi lai cốt thì
thành ra là tất cả mọi thứ đều sẽ kiểu
như như như là mình cốt bình thường có
thật để mà mình thấy có vấn đề thì mình
tìm cách giải quyết nó như thế nào và
mình cậu
sẽ Cốt nó như nào trong mất bao lâu này
có thứ mình tin là có thể trả tầm 1
tiếng thôi sẽ ra được một vấn đề gì đấy
có thể giải quyết được luôn là gì gì đó
à à
Ừ ông kia nói vụ làm ăn gì đấy
ờ ờ
Ok Nói chung là bây giờ không dài dòng
nữa Bây giờ mình đi học cốc luôn không
có mà không Buổi tâm sự chia sẻ với
cả nó like cốt mà nó họ có thể có có
nhiều bạn xem thì sẽ khó hiểu một tí
Mình sẽ giải thích từng người từng cái
mình đang làm
là một các bạn sẽ học hỏi được ít nhất
một ít gì đó
còn nếu mày không hiểu thì chắc là phải
về sau các bạn học chưa sau là trình hơn
mình có bạn sẽ hiểu đối ngoại
Ừ nhưng mà nói chung là đây là một buổi
gần như là để các bạn hình dung được lập
trình viên là sẽ giữ gì bài toán như thế
nào kết hợp việc là
dùng ra clip cái thứ mình đang dạy thì
nó sẽ làm được những gì ông ạ A và
các bạn nhìn thấy cũng sẽ quen dần phải
quen dần nó việc à vì sau mình sẽ làm
như thế
đầu tiên thì mình cho các bạn lý do đó
ngoại lý do tại sao lại có cái
tự nhiên làm cái tu này thì để mình cho
bạn xem thì
Anh có phải bạn để ý là mình đôi khi
mình phải trả lời vì chúng luận để của
các bạn ở trên cái tra này khá là muộn
thậm chí là đôi khi quên bởi vì sao bây
giờ sử là bây giờ mình vào với tư cách
của sinh viên điện đầu nhọn vào tôi cách
sinh viên thì sinh viên sẽ xem được
Kiểu
bài học với cả bình luận như thế này có
vài bình luận thì mình không trả lời vì
cũng người ta chỉ câu cảm thán và ra chả
có hỏi gì cả Nếu mình không trả lời Ờ
nhưng mà có những cái bình luận mà rõ ra
là họ bình luận dụ là đáp án các thứ thứ
muốn mình trả lời Nhưng mà mình vẫn
không không để thấy không Thấy bởi vì
sao Bởi vì công cụ của bên admin này
mình sẽ cho các bạn sẽ thảm công cụ về
Nami nhé Thế bạn thấy là nó chẳng hỗ trợ
cho mình một cái gì cả Đây
khi hòa mình chơi màu da nhưng mà về cơ
bản thì mình thế hỗ trợ được cái gì cả
Bởi vì sao mình cho các bạn xem thử
cho nó một là nó sẽ cho mình xem thấy
bình luận tương tự giống hệt kiểu Ấn ấn
nữa ấn vào preview nó sẽ hiển thị là
toàn bộ bình luận giống hệt như ở bên
như thế này có phần thông báo có phân
thông báo nếu mà đây ấn vào
thông báo qua thông báo ở chiến tranh
này không có chỉ có thông báo qua Email
thôi Thế nên là thế nên là ai ai mà kiểu
bình luận gì thì mình sẽ được nhận thông
báo qua email
ừ ừ
à à
ờ ờ
đi đái kiểu kiểu như này Đấy thì mình
còn biết được nhưng mà Đấy là nếu thông
báo có Email thì còn biết được và bấm mà
trả lời cho nhiều lúc nó sẽ bị trôi nhớ
lúc nó vẫn sẽ bị trôi mình thì toàn phải
chơi cơ chế là trả lời được xong Email
nào mình phải xóa luôn
à à Con chó nhà mình nó đòi chơi cùng mà
kệ đi à
Ừ ừ
Mình mình phải xóa cái email rồi đi
Ừ để để mà cậu nó nó gửi mail mới còn
biết đi
còn không thì như mình đã nói bấm vào
cái bên thằng con mình này
thì nó sẽ hiển thị ra hiển thị ra là
kiểu toàn bộ bình luận như thế này mình
cũng không hề nhìn theo kiểu này nhá
mình không hề biết được là bình luận nào
là bình luận
chưa trả lời rồi bình luận nào đã trả
lời
ô ồ gần đây mới có thêm này ở hình như
gần đây mới có thêm này
Ừ nhưng mà nó vẫn đi Ừ lần này Bây giờ
có vẻ có mới có thêm cái vụ là
hiển thị ra bình luận của mình rồi hồi
trước là chị có hiển thị bình luận mới
không phải của mình ấy thành ra là mình
còn không biết được có bình luận này đã
trả lời đấy chưa Nhưng mà kể cả như này
Ok gần đây có vẻ Thằng này mới thêm cái
vụ như thế này
để mà mình biết được là
anh bình luận là mình đã trả lời hay
chưa
ở ở dưới này cũng có vẻ ổn rồi
Nghe có vẻ ổn ví dụ Giả sử những bình
luận này bình luận này như này chưa trả
lời đúng ạ để mình thử bấm và xem đường
link nhá xem Đúng là bình luận này chưa
trả lời hay chưa
Ừ đúng rồi bình luận này trả lời ok ok
nghĩa bây giờ mình sẽ hướng dẫn Nếu thế
từ hướng dẫn từ bên này trước đi nghĩa
là với ở cái trang này đúng ạ với cái
trang này thì mình lấy ra tất cả những
cái bình luận chưa trả lời sau đó thì
mình sẽ dạy các bạn là Nếu giả sử giống
như là là mình không vào được cái tôn
này là sử mình không phải lánh im hoặc
là mình không biết cái không có cái phân
tu này hay vân vân vân thì thực ra cốt
Mình thấy có khi tương tự thôi là mình
sẽ vẫn phải dựa trên trang này vẫn là
kiểu bình luận tra và bình luận con đúng
không ạ Nếu mà thằng bình luận con mà
không phải là mình Ừ cái bình luận con
và bình luận con cuối là Nhạn mà không
phải là mình thì mình mới bắt đầu lấy
cái bình luận đấy Ra lấy ra thì có thể
theo kiểu dạng là đánh dấu bôi màu nó
lên cái cách đơn giản cách phức tạp hơn
thì có thể là xóa những bình luận à bình
luận mà đã được trả lời đi sẽ dùng ra ra
Switch để mà ẩn chính xác ẩn Đi kiểu ẩn
những cái thang màn ví dụ Giả sử mấy cái
hàng này trả lời được rồi đúng không ạ
thì xóa nó đi
bí ẩn nó đi để mà những cái hàng còn thì
hiện vẫn vẫn còn ở đấy để mình nhìn nó
chúng người dùng Nhìn cái à
ý là hiểu được là bình luận nào chưa trả
lời chẳng hạn thế
cho các bạn hiểu và mình ý định mình
đang muốn làm không ạ
sữa chua các bạn bây giờ cứ coi nhờ hiểu
gì nhé ạ
ở buổi lai cốt này là không cần các bạn
phải xem trực tiếp lắm à mà gần như là
để các bạn xem qua họ xem lại cảm thấy ở
kiểu về sau mình muốn làm việc tôn gì đó
thì mình có chỗ này mà thử tham khảo
đúng
à à
ở
đầu tiên thì sẽ là như thế này
ở đầu tiên làm cần là
ở đây Thằng đấy con này cha con
Nghe có vẻ là thằng này làm tối đa là 3
cấp nếu các bạn đấy kỹ là tui ấn trả lời
ở đây nhưng có vẻ đó xem thẳng ở đây xem
Chị xem ở bên này thì
U Minh Thượng
đã test này cho nạ
Ừ đúng rồi Thằng này tối đa là 3 cấp
ô kê
Ừ
vợ cho dù bấm trả lời các thủ các thứ
nữa thì chắc là nó sẽ chỉ có thứ ba là
tối đa thôi
Ừ mình không cần phải làm phức tạp theo
cậu là đệ quy kiểu là kiểm tra thằng con
vì thằng con thằng con nữa các thứ thứ
mình sẽ kiểm tra tình cấp thứ ba sau đó
cái cái thằng này nó hơi bị dị ở điểm là
thậm chí ấy mình có thể trả lời ngay
trên này như này à
Ừ thế này đúng không ạ
Thế thì thằng này nó sẽ chèn vào giữa
như thế này chèn ở ngay dưới như thế này
thì có việc để mà kiểm tra Chuẩn đấy thì
mình sẽ phải mình sẽ phải là kiểm tra
xem
ờ ờ
cái
đây câu này mình tí mình sẽ tách chuỗi
kiểm tra xem là cái thời gian
thời gian cầu so sánh thời ra nó không ạ
thời gian xem là cái bình luận này như
như nào có bằng bằng thời gian hay không
ít nghĩa lý thế của Ý Thực ra ở đây chắc
là không biết được bình luận này trả lời
chưa này ngon
chợ hoa mình để bỏ qua nếu mà trong
trường hợp bằng cấp như này cũng được
thì các bạn nãy nghe có hiểu na ná gì
không
À mà thôi chưa hiểu thì cứ từ từ sẽ hiểu
không ạ độ đầu tiên à cách để cốt ra
Switch ở trên trang này thì mình sẽ mở
inspect đây này
thì mình sẽ bấm vào suốt Ở đây này ạ
sau đó thì ở đây nó sẽ có khi bấm vào
chuộc lúc đầu các bạn các bạn ấn vào bên
sleep AD nhé
xe tải sau đó News ni pat này Đấy thôi
các bạn sẽ code Speed trong này sau khi
mà cốc xong ấy thì các bạn sẽ chỉ việc
chuột phải ở gần như thế này thì nó cốc
cho biết con sẽ được chạy lại trên trang
này
ở đầu tiên thì ở mình cần lấy toàn bộ
được hoàn toàn toàn bộ những cái xe nhà
anh bình luận tra cách để mà lấy được
cái những cái bình luận cha như này Ừ
thì mình sẽ có trò là kiểu chọn này vào
này chọn cái này
em chưa chọn xong được như này chồng mẹ
chuẩn rồi nè
ở đây Đây là cái bình luận tra đúng
không ạ
ở đây là một cái bình luận này
anh xô ngồi nó sẽ là
có một cái bình luận nữa Ok
a baby sẽ lấy từng cái Cúc cụ mình luận
một bởi vì nó liên quan theo
đã từng làm một như lai của bạn sẽ thấy
một này hay này ba các thứ đây không ạ
Ê bà toàn bộ thằng này nằm trong một
thằng lớn này
em gửi xem nha
Ừ Ok mẹ ăn chị đã
Ê thằng lớn này nó sẽ chứa tưởng thằng
con này một và từng thằng con này sẽ
khác biệt nhau bởi cái á test ID data
that ID đóng ạ
thì tại sao đặt tên là tax ID
Ừ ok
Ừ thì các bạn thấy có sân class này
không ạ
chỉ mình cách để mà lấy cái thằng
It is in class này thì cách cách tìm lấy
tiện ấy thì mình sẽ dùng really mà lấy
ngay nếu các bạn biết ở dưới Côi rồi Cốt
nó sẽ dễ hơn để mà chạy cái trang này có
thể chưa có gj để mà chạy được rồi các
bạn chỉ việc à Nên gj này bà school cả
cả bình thường làm kiểu như này
ạ sau đó thì ở đây có sẵn cái đường link
sên CN của nó
đây thì đây là cốt g-switch giờ để mở
có cái thư viện gd cho mình sẽ gắn trên
C không ạ sau đó thì mình ạ
sang iPad này mình tạo một cái là Smith
PepsiCo di dùng copy ở đây so với giờ
mình chỉ cực đoan nó
Chị nói là nó bằng chuối không ạ thì tức
thì tất cả là sự Huy trên trang này đã
được có sau đó thì mình muốn Cốt về mà
lấy ra
Ừ cái mà mình vừa nãy nói hơi class này
không ạ thì mình chỉ được đơn giản như
này
a section mê
xong gọi đến high-class là
a night
bộ đèn không
bí đao Xem Tại sao À đúng rồi class này
cách thì nó phải chấm Cái phát nữa
a Plan không ạ truyền
[âm nhạc]
e class
à à
Chờ Đợi mình tí sẽ chạy sang
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
Ừ đúng rồi nhá hai cách này ra sai nhỉ
ở tuổi mình xem cái thằng mình đang kết
nối đến xem chuẩn luôn à
à à
à à nhưng phải biết liền Ok biết liền
đô la này này à
anh có đây đấy lấy ra được cái thằng này
không ạ
thì mình sẽ là đô la ngày tiếp rồi tại
vị trí được 01 vì thằng Hai luôn chả
phải dạng mạng này
nó sẽ ra được hàng ngày và thằng ngày
cần lấy thằng con của nó là và
em lấy con của nó sẽ là toàn bộ những
cái đít
comment như thế này
ở đây mình đang lấy theo lần lượt từ
chàng trai thì thằng con nó không ạ lấy
tất cả những thằng con
thì mình sẽ mất file này sau đó thì mình
sẽ là
đít này nếu mà lấy đơn giản chị Deep
không thì thằng con này nó sẽ bao gồm cả
những cái đít nó không liên quan nó là
cái đít
phân tranh này có hai cái đít Phương
tranh từ đầu cô ấy thì mình không cần
lấy mấy cái đít đấy mình sẽ cần lấy mấy
cái đít mà nó có cái đoạn ạ datapath ID
này đúng không ạ thì mình sẽ có dùng như
thế này là ta
chị sẽ chữa data that ID ạ
à à
khi
chạy thử này
à à
a file
a file Đúng rồi nhỉ
ở nơi để xem nhé á
I find it
anh phá
ở tiệm file Zip xem nào
nổi loạn này cái này ạ nằm trong cái này
đi à
à à
Ừ ok rồi này
Ừ thì đây sẽ data Tết hay đi à
à à
chờ
đợi mình đi nhá
cái vụ hát are to view
the Switch là gì quên mất rồi
à à
ở xã the Musical this
Sector
nãy giờ mình đang viết nó hơi khó hiểu
về cái vụ selector
thì các bạn thấy nãy giờ mình đang viết
kể vụ sợi tơ này là tìm kiếm cụ thể sẽ
nó nó thằng nào
Ừ nếu nó có sếp anh chị điều này
cho nên values
ô kê
à à
ừ ừ
Ê
Nhớ à Cũng không tên gì vậy
anh Đợi mình tí cũng như có cái vụ Không
Tên
à Mà bao gồm cái à
đã bao gồm cả Annabelle gì đó ừ ừ
vì tình chôn
tên là chứa
chú đại minh các bạn thấy các bạn nhớ
cái vụ cách ra như thế này nó sẽ làm cả
ê CPU này thì mình cần lời cái đít à cái
thật cái này đít mà có cái chữ IQ là
data that đúng không ạ à
Ừ đấy mình nhớ ghi kiểu nghe được là mày
He has multiple spectre là như thế này
là được em nhé
Cho xem tuần sau nhé
a fine
à À đúng rồi Mình nào xin lỗi xin lỗi mà
sao chị mới sai
Ừ đúng rồi data gạch ngang đời Ok rồi
rồi ra 38 cái Xin lỗi Xin lỗi
U23 đầu đến giai đoạn nào thôi Đây thì
đây cái toàn bộ Cái này sẽ lấy được toàn
bộ mình sẽ đặt tên một cái là Olay
số comment là Nhạn không ạ
Ở đây toàn bộ comment
Ừ nhưng mà thực ra gì để mình xem lại
nhé
chị Xuka là mình mình cần lấy ở đây là
mình không hẳn là cần lấy toàn bộ
comment
ở đâu sao á đúng luôn đúng với toàn bộ
Comment này được xong rồi bên bên trong
Comment này nữa mình sẽ đặt tên Đây là
ai comment
ở
turin comment nghĩa là đây à là bình
luận Cha
Sau đó mình sẽ đặt một cái như này
à à
ạ sau đó đi với tầng thằng bình luận tra
này sẽ có bình luận con của nó đúng
Ừ rồi mình sau đó đi mình à Chỉ đơn giản
là mình chạy vòng lặp lấy từng với cái
từng bình luận cha mình sẽ chạy kiểm tra
xem nó có bình luận con hay không Nếu mà
có rồi thì mình
À có rồi thì mình bỏ qua đúng ạ Còn nếu
không thì mình mình đánh dấu nó lại đúng
ạ Mình sẽ đàng Giàu nó lại thấy kiểu thế
anh
bình tĩnh Nằm mấy ông tôi vẫn đang thuê
lại ốm tính thôi I
a waitress
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
à à
cho Android fre phối Đúng rồi nhỉ
ừ ừ
em thích đi à
ở Samsung à
ở đó tôi sẽ Tinh thần này
à à
hai a thì cái này mấy hôm Có thể thêm
sau mà không Tạm Chấp nhận đi
mình giả sử mình sẽ lót từ thằng xa1 con
số đo chân nó từng Hằng X là một này để
xem
Ê nó lấy như thế nào
I was Slow Rock màu da
ex2 đây thì hình như nó đang là số à
có
khách à
a
recluse anh
à à
chỉ có mình sẽ cầm lấy cái thằng baru
chúng mình không cần lấy cái thằng đâu
ok
à à
thì mình sẽ cần lấy cái thằng nhà thằng
thứ hai này mình bỏ qua thằng đầu tiên
có show lock inactive Alo này nó sẽ là
nó hai cái thằng in ra giá trị của thằng
trước và đằng sau mình cần lấy làm sau
thôi đúng ạ à
có một cái này
Ừ từ điển hình xem lại nhé xem mình có
chuẩn đô thích không
Ừ mình ở luôn xem lại kiểm tra rồi ạ
Đây đầu tiên là cái bình luận đầu tiên
đây đúng không ạ sẽ có đi flash con tên
này lại thằng
ở đầu tiên thì mình xem dần đi mình mình
xem lần trước khi cốt đi đó là mình xem
xe mà đây thằng cha mày chứ sợ thằng cha
đúng không ạ ạ
Ê thằng cha thằng con nó như là bỏ qua
không quan trọng
ta có
ở đây mấy thằng con này nghĩa đây sẽ có
hai thằng ngày 2 ngày khác nhau Điểm gì
à hài khác nhau là điểm là
ở đây à đây Nho sẽ gạch chéo nhau để
hiểu là trả lời bình luận à
Ừ đúng
ở một hàng như này một thằng kiểu vạch
chéo săn mồi có nội dung của thằng cha
như thế này chéo cái nhiều trả lời bình
luận Chắc thế thì xem nhé phanthanh
em trả lời bình luận và Phan Thanh ok
rồi này ta sử đây đi bình luận được trả
lời rồi bình thường bình luận chưa trả
lời cho mà á hay bình luận ở bên dưới
xem à bình luận này
anh bình luận này Ok này đây bình luận
của Mister yeah cái bình luận trả lời
bình luận này
ạ sau đó thì đi bình luận trả lời bình
luận bình luận này
ở đây
ạ sau đó thì đây là bình luận trả lời
nữa
anh bình luận trả lời nữa
số bài 1 2 3 4 cấp Lan Tổng cộng là 4
cấp
Ừ nhưng mà mình như mình vừa nãy nói đó
là hình như nó chỉ giới hạn nhà này cấp
thôi nó sẽ không có hơn nữa và
Ừ ok
ở đầu tiên thì mình làm theo kiểu đơn
giản nhất nhé Thì mình cần lấy á bình
luận cuối
anh bình luận cuối của từng bình luận
Cha đi đúng
ừ ừ
Anh Bình trí xăm đồng hồ ở bình luận
cuối của từng bị luận tra vừa nãy mình
đã làm được lấy bình luận tra đúng không
ạ Bên mình sẽ lấy bình luận cuối của
Cường bị kiểm tra sau đó đi
Anh ở Xem kết quả mà như thế nào đã
nếu các bạn thấy ở thời ra nó đều có cái
đít cái lá này dipso cả cục class này
có cách cách cách để phải lấy cái chị sẽ
ở tạm lưu và này ra đây đã
cách tạo xóa này đi cho trông đợi chồng
này cách để lấy cái thằng này mình sẽ
đôla
không này
ở đó sẽ có các cụ như này cho có mạng dễ
lấy
à à Ừ
anh xe ôm lên
bây giờ sẽ là
Ừ
chị sẽ dùng djeep find a
à à
nhờ các cụ như này
không sờ trong đó cả cụ này đi à
anh từng thầm Cha
em rửa chạy Huỳnh tra
xem nhé chạy từ thằng cha xong rồi lấy
như thế này
ý chạy thử
áo len là không
chỉ có mỗi một cái có
Khi so sánh Tại sao có mỗi một cái có
à À đây b bình luận cấp con mất rồi hàng
ở trên cung thì nó sẽ chị học cái class
ngày thôi không có hẳn class đít
ê kê Thế thì mình sẽ bỏ nó đi bi a
ừ ừ
anh xóa classis này đi
à à
anh Hải có hai cá này
có hay không có cái nào
Khi nào xem thử nhé
ở những trường hợp đầu nó có này
a-class này
The Flash ngay dưới này nữa kê là bình
luận đây bình luận tra này bình luận a
bình luận Con này đúng ạ thằng dưới này
em nói không có
em không có thằng Hà
em xem lại sau nhé
Ở phần dưới này có cùng class này
cả ngày cũng có class
này Tại sao không ra nhỉ
a file Zip container
a MB
Ừ chắc chắn ở cái này xem like cốt rồi
mà không ai vui gì cả ngồi lập trình Mày
lập trình đôi khi ở ngồi mò bắt nó không
vui gì cả nhưng mà khi mà ra đồ vật b
thì các bạn mới thấy vui
vì mình không thể hài hước lúc mình đang
ngồi lập trình được nghe buồn cười lắm
ừ ừ
cho hai thằng đang bình thấy hai thằng
này là không khác gì nhau cả hai tôi bận
bắt đầu lúa ơi
Em hãy phát biểu nhỉ the
à à
à à à à
ừ ừ
à à
vì nó không trả về cái gì
nó hơi bị lạ vì thế cái đoạn này lại
à à
đầu tiên là có Slow Rock Is this a
tử vi Thì chả thế hết này
Ừ hỏi đi đây
Ừ ai cũng có 1 Một Ngày Đơn giản ít
anh không class luôn
Ừ hỏi đi
Cho tôi xem nhạc ngựa À đây rồi rồi rồi
Mình hiểu sao rồi thằng này đi và
I need to
32 clip
em vẫn vẫn là cái nick đấy đúng không
Bạn ý như là vẫn là cái đấy
em biết mày đi
Ừ Rồi rồi rồi giờ rồi à nghĩa cái đoạn
là repellent comment của mình bị say mất
rồi đây đít to này mình chỉ cần lấy con
nít to thôi Nhưng đây Cái này nhảy thẳng
vào thằng đi con nữa rồi
à à
anh bảo sao
ở đây nó nó nhảy lần lượt là thằng đi
con mất rồi
operon của mình có vấn đề rồi
à à
Cho xem lại kết đoạn avatar ơn nhé
à À đây lấy toàn bộ thằng con mất rồi
thì sẽ cần lấy thằng
Ê thằng à
Ừ đúng nếu file thế này thì nó tìm cả
thằng con của bên trong rồi chứ không
cần nó không lấy mỗi thằng cha nữa
Ừ đúng rồi mẹ ơi các bạn đang xem sẽ
dung.di Nhưng bản chất Cái này là ra
Swift thôi còn nếu các bạn giết bằng
Rocket thuần thì cái đoạn nào sẽ dày hơn
nhiều nhưng phải giữ Huy Cho đoạn ngắn
hơn tí
à à
em xem lại cái vụ này phát
Ừ đúng rồi
ở đây đây anh bảo sao nãy ở không ra
ngày mình mình cần lấy những cái thằng
Mít luôn à
Ê kíp không có không có cái à flag đầu
ngồi có data-id nhưng không có class là
được ok thì đoạn này sẽ là
nó các bạn sẽ biết về khái niệm lót nữa
ờ ờ ờ
I know selector Perry
anh nghe này
thì mình sẽ là Note II
chị
sẽ không có class thì sẽ là class a
à à
ở đài chuẩn rồi nó vẫn như này đúng này
Đấy tất cả thằng cha ok rồi đúng không
ở đó sau đó đi bây giờ mình sẽ gán lại
biến
I let recomment đúng ạ
khi mở thì k0 lét lét rồi về ở đây con
mẹ father comment bằng cả cục ngay đi ở
đó đó thì mình sẽ lấy lại con Slowrock
rít như thế này ra được nhà Chuẩn rồi
chọn rồi
Ừ nó sau đó lấy thằng con nhưng ai
ở đó được ngay
Ừ mẹ uống đúng Bà tôi Lũ
cho hàm nốt là sẽ là kiểu
chị sẽ lấy những thằng nào không chứa
không chừa cái gì đó
hàng rất hay
Em hãy selector này selector tương tự
với xe CS nhé các bạn nhờ ông ạ Các bạn
nhiều cái vụ ạ mặt vuông này để lấy cái
ax CPU này nót này nó cũng Thực ra cũng
giống mua xe hết rồi chấm này cũng sẽ
này không Nếu mà thẻ không thì không có
gì trước kiểu ghi tên Hẹn này của xe này
đúng không ạ
Đúng rồi cái note này giữa hai mình rất
thích dùng Note
và có nếu mà ID thì tham nóng ạ Nó dùng
Center giống xe thôi
Á Đại Thành
ở đó sau đó lấy lần lượt ngay thôi Đúng
ừ ừ
ở
đây mình sẽ là thay Đây là nét à mình sẽ
à play
comment bằng như này chẳng hạn đúng ạ
à à
ở đầu tiên thì mình sẽ chơi theo kiểu là
anh với với từng hành vi tuần hoàn ra
thì mình lại
ở mình thường hay làm chơi cái trò là
mình sẽ cho một cái biến
có cái khái niệm là cái biến gọn trong
lập trình nó sẽ có cái khái niệm là gắn
cờ nghĩa mình lúc đầu mình sẽ cho mặc
định nó bằng phone là sai ạ
xôi khi mà có xuất hiện cái trả lời bình
luận của mình của mình nhé và ý ra có
trả lời bình luận Giả sử thế thì mình sẽ
đổi nó bằng chu với từng cái bình luận
tra một mình sẽ luôn kiểm tra lại mình
sẽ lúc đầu chị cho bằng phone thì sẽ tạo
sẽ cho một cái đã chết comment như thế
này lại
chỉ Comment này sẽ bạn bằng Phone này
Lúc đầu như thế này sau đó thì
mọi chuyện lại vui Tưng hay tiếp
em copy đầy tiếp này
anh gà thế này bỏ cái Index Cứ thử đi
chứ không dùng cái này á
khi
con solo lót thằng Zip
xem được chưa đã
luôn phải in lại xem nó đầy đủ ổn chưa
bạn trong trường hợp này Zip chính là
lần lượt thằng từng thằng con một nhé
vị trí
dịch vụ khác
à à
Ê thằng con này nó ôm cả thằng con nữa
hỗ trợ miễn phí file Zip này
ừ ừ
à à
ở đây vẫn hạt repellent mất rồi Thế mình
đang sai đấy
khả năng mình đang lấy thằng này đang
thì sẽ So sánh thằng
bài
viết này ở trong trường hợp này là lấy
thằng à tra rồi mà nhỉ
Ừ tra lại nhảy vào đánh con à
À
mà bạn rồi à
Ý
anh nói là gì ạ
à à
cô gái rõ ràng ngày
ừ ừ
à Hôm nay không làm biến đi
sẽ không cần biến đi cho thằng muộn hoài
chạy vội ích gì cho chắc
ừ ừ
à à
ở trong gg nó bị nó bị cái thằng giết là
đôi khi các bạn sẽ rất dễ bị loạn thằng
ri trong trường hợp này nó khác bằng rít
trong trường hợp trong này bị loạn là
mềm đấy
ở đó bây giờ chuẩn rồi này đấy thằng con
này à
Vì sao nó thì lấy thằng con tiếp này đó
con này
à còn thế mày Ok rồi nè
à à
I phone nếu trong trường hợp mà
anh có trả lời bình luận là có
mình mình xe khách đi lại pháp xem lại
đi
ảnh hài khó trở lại bình luận thì lại
khác nhau Điểm gì Thằng này sẽ có một
cái đít nữa
ừ ừ
Ừ
từ nhất là độ dài của nó cần lớn không
chẳng hạn
chị lớn không thì mình đã gọi à mình mới
bắt đầu kiểm tra tiếp xem thằng thằng
con thằng con kể tiếp
Ê thằng con
à à
chị xem nhé
À mà thôi Chọn chẳng cần phải lớn đúng
không Mình sẽ xem thẳng
Ê thằng Hà à cuối bình thường ấy làm
mình sẽ lấy lát thay vì ích mình sẽ lời
Leg
sữa nesquik thằng cuối này
ý nghĩa thế hợp lý hơn và sẽ nhanh hơn
rất nhiều lấy thằng cuối sau đó thì mình
à kiểm tra đến thằng đấy
chị thay mình dùng X mình sẽ dùng flash
thì phải đã cho IQ Đi xa mà
ừ ừ
à à
I
crashed thử thử
a12x
cơ
thể thành con cuối này thử con solo.net
thằng cuối
thằng bình luận cuối của từng thằng
à à
Ừ ừ
thì đấy Thời ca là ông là bình luận phía
sau thì thời ca mình chưa trả lời cái
bình luận của ông phía sau cũng đúng mà
mình mình mình đang nghĩ là như thế bạn
Bạn hiểu ý mình ngọn bởi vì thằng này nó
hơi bị nhược điểm một tí nếu như bạn vừa
nãy bạn thấy là thực ra ngày mình đàn em
mình mình trả lời trả lời bình luận đấy
khi tác giả sử mình trả lời bình luận
cho bạn này ở đây mình bị trả lời bình
luận đây này thì rõ ràng là đúng Bạn
thấy nó nhảy nó chèn vào ở dưới bình
luận như thế này đúng bọn nó không tạo
ra cấp nữa nhưng mà rõ ra là nó lại trả
lời bình luận ngay rửa như này chứ không
phải nhảy xuống cuối đúng
A B có bao nhiêu điểm nghĩa trong trường
hợp mà giả sử bình luận này của bạn đấy
cuối là cảm ơn mình này bình luận này
của mình là trả lời bình luận này Ở trên
bạn đấy này thì thì rõ ràng là đúng là
mình mình bị sai là theo kiểu là mình
không Mình không lấy được cái bình chuẩn
là mình đã trả lời bình luận này rồi
Em hãy đợi khá như thế bạn đấy có hại
chờ có hai bình luận đây mình trả lời
bình luận bạn đấy ở ở đây này đúng không
Thì rõ ràng là có bình luận cuối thì lại
lấy ra là mình chưa trả lời bình luận
bạn đấy
anh Thịnh Nếu mà thế chuẩn ra là mình
phải lấy thời gian của bình luận chuẩn
nhất là lấy thời gian của bình luận và
xem cái thời gian cuối là mình bình luận
thì nó mới đúng đó ngoại ngữ mà Ở đây
các bạn đang thấy mình không biết ở
trong cái trong này nó có lưu 20 em nhờ
các bạn đang thấy ở đây đó là cái bình
luận này nó đó không lưu lại cái thời
gian thực sự của bình luận được trả lời
đúng ạ Các bạn chỉ thấy là phô đây gần
xong rồi các thứ thứ như thế này thì cái
việc nếu mà trả lời cùng một ngày thì
đương nhiên là rõ ràng là cái đây câu
này nó chảy nghĩa gì cả đúng không ạ Nó
cần phải giờ phút giây ý nghĩa là như
thế thì mới so sánh được bình luận nào
trước bình luận là con không Mình đang
chấp nhận lấy bình luận cuối thôi
Ừ thôi thế đơn giản
à à
Em thử nhắn
anh bình luận quái
khi con thỏ
Ê hồi nãy tôi được bỏ qua bài con trọ
nghe nói khó lắm Mày thấy tôi về học
gì đấy Đang lại bình luận quấy bị cuối
này thì rất đơn giản rồi bây giờ mình sẽ
tìm việc là
ý đến cái phần à Thằng ạ Con
đi hoa cà hoa cà để cho tối ưu hơn là
không phải dùng cốt cho mỗi mình mình mà
dùng cốt cho các à
anh nói chung là các thầy thầy khác đấy
thấy khác giờ sư thầy khác cũng mùa lên
xem ấy đúng ạ
Ừ thì mình nghĩ là qua cái chữ in chắc
in chapter này được nhưng mà inter này
thì đúng là ở trên tra này mới thấy con
trên trang này có vẻ không thấy này trên
trang này có vẻ không thấy
à à Manchester này nó lại sử ấy nghe
mình trong Buồn cười quá
đây thì mình nghĩ à mình sẽ lấy đến cái
đoạn có span là là class như thế này
được
à à
hôm nay mình sẽ chỉ rồi à
thế âm inh bỏ như thế thì không cần cá
này nữa mình sẽ chị chỉ việc file này
đúng ạ xong rồi có thằng spam này sâu có
cái class này là được
a-class này
ở đó như này chắc thế
ở đó
chị
thơ Con solo rock cái thằng này ra xem
được đúng không nhá
à à
do đó nếu không sẽ thấy có phải ra đúng
không ạ Đây
Ê thằng ngày có bình luận trả lời
chị Hằng anh dưới này
Chưa có bình luận trả lời
đây đúng không có bình luận trả lời
không ạ Ê thằng ở dưới này không có bình
luận trả lời này xem xem lần lượt nhé
nhà hàng dưới này có bình luận trả lời
này Trần Thị Linh Phương không bình luận
trả lời
anh đúng không Bạn Phương
anh không không có bình luận trả lời
đúng ạ đó thế xong rồi cốt mình tương
đối thế nào rồi ạ đó là mình mình như
này thì mình sẽ lấy được rồi ông ạ
ạ Bây giờ mình à sẽ mình sẽ đặt tên nó
Nó là check
An xơ là đúng ạ ăn xơ
biết nhà anh Sơn nghe đúng không ạ
Ừ tự nhiên tự nhiên tôn đủ tiếng Anh à à
à
à Chuẩn bị tại
ngay.me này
là độ dài đây là sẽ lấy độ dài
ít check answers à
E bằng bằng không đi
Hạnh bao giờ bà này nó sắp đi
Ừ từ collar người rất là nó trả về chỉ
có số thôi Hay dầu bằng cũng thường được
rồi nhưng mà để phẳng
có ai và
nếu mà nó bằng 0 thì sao thì mình sẽ cho
cái thằng cha đầy vẫn nhớ thằng giết ở
trong trường vỡ thằng cha không ạ Nhưng
sẽ cho nó mua cái màu gì đó
cách đổi background cho nó cũng được ý
nghĩa như thế vì sai cho nó này
mình nhớ vụ Stars background
Style back ground
floor print
I said sấm sét
vì vậy
thông tin
à à
có Zalo à cũng được thử Phát
anh Alo Nó ra đường ông ạ
cho nó hợp lý rồi hợp lý rồi xem xem xem
thử nha xem thử kết quả nhé
anh bình luận này chưa trả lời hết này
đúng rồi này bình luận mài quấy ra là
bạn này trả lời thêm cái câu này khiến
cho bình luận của mình hàng chi trả lời
này ông ạ
khi đó Xuân đối
á nhon nữa đây Thế là xong rồi
ở Cốt nó sẽ chỉ hai thôi à
thì mình sẽ ôm cốt này sang đây này và
cái vụ Android comment kia tôi bị lạc
lối đi cái đoạn comment rồi để xem Đấy
lại được Eric comment 0
xe tải đã
I read a
nhờ các cụ ngày nay
có điều lạ đã bây giờ mình tại lại tra
chơi lại từ đầu nhé
Ừ nó
ạ bây giờ để chạy li này jean thằng này
sau đó thì Loan hàng ngày
Ờ Ờ có gì sai sai hẹn rồi bình tĩnh bình
tĩnh có gì sai rồi
Hà Tĩnh Nha
à à
Anh sợ thế này nhé
vợ chồng có phải thoang đấy bình tĩnh
à Tôi đang đi thằng uruk Comment này có
vấn đề
Ừ đúng rồi nhá Đúng không xa
em ở đâu đâu cốt vẫn đúng có phản ứng
bình tĩnh nhé xài Chắc là chỉ sai mỗi
thằng mà
Anh Hai đang bị sai này đúng là bị sai à
hai a Rồi
tự tự Bình xá bình luận đi cái này ra
chữ tự nhiên lại có thể vào chữ đi la ở
đây Bỏ sao nó lỗi
ở Đà Lạt Mình bị nhầm mình tưởng dữ liệu
cũ đây cho Android cho cô vẫn chuột của
mày thế
khi mình xóa xóa đi rồi vẫn còn bị biến
đi này ok
Ừ nhưng mà ôm người cốt này không thể
sang bên này được vì các bạn hãy giao
diện rồi nó bị khác đúng không ạ
Mình cứ gửi sang Hàn trang mới rồi nhé
Sang hạn trong mơ thấy
khi chạy thử lại
ở đó
á nhon ngay Xanh mới này có vẻ
anh
sang trăm mười này có vẻ là không cần nó
nó đang không đoán lại tra các bạn để ý
kĩ là nó không nó lại trang nó sẽ dùng
ra Suite để mà tại thế bình luận Xóa
bình luận cụ ẩn Xóa những cái thằng HM
cũ đi để mày hiện bị thêm hát Em vừa mới
loát hai mang tên là lâu mới về nên là
mình không cần phải chạy lại gj mà mình
chỉ cần chạy lại cái
thì mình chỉ cần trả lại cái đoạn code
của mình thôi đầu hoặc đó ông thối vì
thấy thế này tương đối ổn rồi
các bác rau này trông có vẻ hơi bị xấu
một tí xong mấy ông nữa thứ là quan
trọng gì với nó diện đâu là bọn mình
quan trọng với tính năng thôi mình có
phải chạy được tính năng rồi đúng không
ạ
Ừ đấy toàn bộ thằng cha và sẽ được độ
bôi màu vàng xoáy như này lên đó để mà
biết được đấy bình luận này chưa trả lời
đúng ạ bình luận này trả lời dối cuối
cuối bình luận mình trả lời rồi bình
luận này thì có thêm ông này trả lời nữa
mà mình không trả lời thì mình bỏ qua
thôi đúng ạ
ở nhà ông thiếu của nó không ạ Đấy Ủa
mày Thế năm rồi năm nhằm số quá đẹp
ờ ờ tương tự Thế mình có thể làm bên này
Anh có thể làm bên này các bạn thấy là
cái cái cách mình làm thực ra nó cũng nó
cũng có thể tương tự thôi đúng ạ Không
biết mày ông muốn mua xem tôi có thêm
không ngờ tôi thấy tôi sợ là mày ông cậu
bị nản thôi còn lời việc nãy giờ cốt thì
các bạn thấy đây bảy nòng cốt để làm một
cái tung anh không hoàn nhanh mất sự cầm
tiếng đồng hồ
nhưng mà
Ê mấy ông có thể nãy giờ không hiểu về
tôi xin phép giảm lại thì đầu tiên thì
cái việc cái này như tôi đã nói thì dùng
cái này bằng vẫn là do Suite nhưng chẳng
qua tôi đang dùng cái thư viện rêu để
mặc nó selector nó nó nó sẽ lách nó
nhanh hơn bởi vì nếu không theo cách
viết kiểu như thế này thì các bạn sẽ nó
comment chấm ghét antimon byte spectre
sau đó thì sẽ theo thẻ này đúng không
class này classf tiếp này số ngồi lấy
thằng đầu tiên đầu tiên tại sao là thằng
đầu tiên bởi vì mình đang muốn lấy thằng
cha tầng ở trên này không ạ
ạ sau đó thì tìm đến những thằng con có
chứa cái cái a'pieu là ngày nay mà không
có class không có class Tại sao với mấy
thằng con này nó có class còn Hoàng tra
thì không có Thế mình chỉ cần lấy thằng
ra thôi em không xuống không chụp đấy
sau Tiếp theo là với từng thằng cha này
mình sẽ lấy thằng thằng con cuối của nó
Nếu bọn thằng con cuối của nó và kiểm
tra xem mà nó có chứa cái thẻ span có
chữ có chữ Lại in chapter này không đóng
ngoặc và kiểm tra độ dày của nó độ dài
của nó thì
cho
mình mình sẽ kiểm tra là Nếu mật độ dày
bằng không thì chắc chắn là nó không nó
không có rồi đó ông ạ Còn độ dài bằng 1
cái bằng hai thì chắc là hiển nhiên nó
có thôi Đấy con Nếu có thì mình sẽ cho
thận trong trường hợp này duelist này nó
sẽ là B đang chạy lần lượt tuần Hoàng
cha đó ạ đô rít sẽ thằng cha luôn mình
sẽ chỉnh CS thằng cha đổi màu background
cho nó đấy
a court 1 tiếng chỉ được bệnh dòng chán
Nhưng mà tôi mà làm cái tool này ngon
hơn tí sau đó thì tôi
anh đem đi bán
chẳng hạn thế Ngủ ngoan khi
có một tí ăn đấy 7 dòng thôi nhé nhấn
mạnh mấy ông lại nó vẫn chỉ là 7 dòng
cốt thôi
anh cũng thể lên đến tìm triệu rồi
Ừ ông mà cho đi thuê nữa Còn giá còn
ngon hơn
ai ai nói ngành công nghệ thông tin là
vua mọi ngày nào ạ
à à
Anh pha Nếu mày Ông cảm thấy bị lừa bị
lười hơn thì bé uống thể chơi cách này
à nếu hoàn toàn có thể
a ghi thẳng vào trong cái nếu bị trên
này của tôi thực ra có rất nhiều cái và
mấy cái này Thực ra nó là ra Spec đây
mình cái này nó là ra Speed đấy
cho mình cũng xem nhé này
Có ai đi à
ở
đây Taylor Swift số phóng chuyển từ thứ
này Ô kìa Nếu có thể chơi từ ra tôi chưa
thử dùng ra sức ép về những cái cái này
để nhúng rugby về đâu
ở nhà để tôi thử phát nha à
em copy cái này à
ở lại thế chắc không sao đâu
ạ
sau đó đi đoạn dưới này
ở
bảng copy toàn bộ đoạn này tạo áp một
cách pet mới đặt tên là à à
Ừ cái cái bồ cũng được đổi toàn bộ váy
này thành dạng Hồ
Ừ nó bị giới hạn ký tự mất rồi có vẻ là
với Yuri thì chóng bị giới hạn ký tự rồi
Ừ Ok như thế thì tôi sẽ Chỉ lấy mỗi cái
đoạn này thôi vậy tham vắt Di nó dài mà
ở
đây à
I hate này
chẳng hạn đấy Dạo này thì chắc là nó
tương đối tạm cực bốc mát ở đây
ừ nếu thế thì mày Ông vẫn phải mở lên để
mà chạy Thế đoạn shiori như này là sử
thôi có lại cho anh nhá qua lại chàng
này
Ừ
cái chim của
sắp xitec của mình
nhúng C đây nở đúng cdn thì à
Ừ Cái quan trọng là mình đang chạy mở ra
Speed không nhúng được CN của đấy
Không không phải là HCl
ờ ờ
em à Đang nói rồi cái quần lót của tôi
người ta có có đề cập vợ nnl này
mày ông lên blog của tôi xem cái sim nhé
cái tôi có chia sẻ đã sắp hết tất nhau
hôm ấy ông muốn đấy à
Ừ đúng được
cho tôi tôi chưa thử thì thôi thử sẽ
cho cây nhưng mà đại khái là tôi chỉ cho
mấy ông mẹo này vào là bé uống thể tạo
iPad vừa rồi đúng không đầy nó lên trên
như này
Xe tôi chạy ở gj này
Ừ vợ anh ở đây à
Ừ em
ở lượt đi em
a
parent notify tôi xóa từ code một dòng
cốt ở trên đời
này làm đúng
à à
ta có
ở Đài Loan như này xong rồi phải bấm ở
đây nữa Nó hơi bất tiện nhỉ Tôi thử tra
cái vụ mà Em bớt làng đúng không gj mà
ra Swift sao
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ tôi chưa làm
à À đây người được chèn những đoạn này
xong này à à
à à
vụ tai nạn sao hết nữa nhé xem được
không
anh bấm mà
em chẳng có gì cả chúng tôi đó Em biết
lỗi rồi
ở đôla nó đi pha đây
300 Nếu mà
anh đi kiểu này thì mình sẽ không dùng
được đô la
a a mình với trùng sau xe tamil sau ạ
nghĩa là cái này nhúng xong rồi sẽ đợi
nó một lúc
Ừ để mà cái tài liệu tải xong cái
t-ara đã trông nó chạy Ok
esp đầu tượng thế nó kiểu túi ở cốt các
bạn Hiển thị cốt ở trên
Anh cứ tưởng là nó chạy Xong rồi nó chạy
xuống dưới đúng ạ Không nó nó có thể nó
chưa kịp chạy lót xong nó đã nhảy xuống
dưới rồi thành ra để ở chắc cú thì các
bạn phải đội nó một khoảng thời gian như
thế này à
à à
ừ ừ
ở đó đồ rồi ok cái mẹo này cũng dị phết
mẹo này kiểu 77 và
đẩy vào HTML một cái đoạn Kiều chứa chứa
thẻ ra Switch chữa ok
I sleep on line mình chưa thử vụ slip-on
launch để mình thử xem nhé
có xe tâm anh thực ra cũng được rồi
em đi xe máy
a
sweet on lot I
Anh hot le stevens
Ừ chị ôm swiftlet loát ở như thế nào
à à
à À đây đây đây đúng không wifi ngay
sông như này ý ông như thế này đúng
không
khi được tôi sẽ thử cách này của ông xe
thermage này Thực ra nó hơi nông dân một
tí là phải đợi khoảng một khoảng thời
gian các thứ trong nó về không chuyên
nghiệp đúng không và có thể là nếu mà
mạnh của ông cùi có thể nó lót Vẫn chưa
xong à
thế này on lock lên tay
bị sẽ biết toàn bộ cái này vào trong đấy
à à
a Weekly test lên trong có vẻ chuyên
nghiệp face
Em
đâu rồi
Em thử lại phát nữa này
Ồ tôi toàn phải tại trang Nếu muốn thử
lại với bây giờ sẽ flash lại Story mà đó
Mong rồi ok đấy Hôm nay bị biết được
thêm cái mới từ chính các bạn không ạ
chính bạn kia ạ
an toàn những Smart ở đây đấy thì cái
này bạn nhưng mà mình đọc cốt thì mình
cũng sẽ hiểu đúng bản chất nó là ở kiểu
chèn thêm cái thẻ ra sweep vào trong HP
pro chèn thêm xuộc nó là cái đoạn đường
dẫn sẽ DN đến cái thư viện gd
chèn thêm vào này và khi mà nó lót được
xong cái Script bậy thì chạy các đoạn
code của mình không ạ Chắc lại code này
ok đi đái thế Ngon rồi
Ý mình bảo đấy sửa tương tự như thế này
thích thì đề bài thật cho các bạn cũng
được đó các bạn thích có thể tự thì mới
hiểu về việc là các bạn à có thể lên cái
trang cái cái bồ vịt các bạn đâu vào
được biến amin này để xem nó đúng ngọn
thì các bạn vào bên tiếp với bồ này nó
cũng tương tự tương tự thôi chẳng qua
khác vì gần như khác với class chứ còn
về logic cốt thì mình thấy nó tương tự
là nó cũng kiểu chia cấp độ như thế các
thứ Thử như thế thì mình chỉ cần kiểm
tra thành thằng con
xem Sọ xem là thằng con nó có phải đến
actor 20 là được đóng lại đây là sao
Ừ ok code này thì mình sẽ để ở bình luận
của vị ở video nhá để các bạn thích các
bạn thể tham khảo
anh cũng hay mà đúng mình vừa trị các
bạn về vụ là ẩn F12 ấn vào con xô để mà
chạy được cô ta Swift này thậm chí là
mình có mình có thể tạo một cái ở trên
này một cái bụp mát ở trên này các bạn
nên dùng bút mắt và không nên dùng mà
không không nên dùng kiểu
Ừ để book Mark về mỗi mấy cái cậu trang
các tự tử nhảy hãy bút mát cả những cái
Swift như thế này để mà các bạn tạo ra
mình có rất nhiều sweep ví dụ điển hình
để tìm kiếm một ai đó giống như bạn
Phương Linh kia chẳng ạ sẽ tìm kiếm như
thế này mình sẽ tìm kiếm bạn tên là
Phương Linh nó sẽ mặc định vào cái tát
people vì mình thực ra là bản chất là
mình truyền cái chữ Trỗi cái Phương Linh
của mình vừa gõ xong rồi vào với Đông Mở
mở trang web mới theo dạng mà kiểu
facebook.com này sốt people cu Bằng
Phương Linh đúng không ạ Hãy kiểu gì thế
ở đó May mà cái buổi like cốt này nó
không Dài quá đúng ạ được một tiếng khá
phù hợp khá ổn rồi đó ông ạ Thôi bây giờ
thì tra các bạn đi nấu cơm đi mình thì
ở Mỹ có thể đi ngủ tiếp
Xin
chào bạn nha
chị xem bé ông ấy Ông thể xem lại sau
nhé
Ừ ok
à à
[âm nhạc]